I was working in the lawyer's office
said enough now I met you write this
novel and I witnessed to see my boss mr.
Hill and I said mr. Hill I'm going to
leave you and I need you writing over
Edward to coast he fell about laughing I
wrote short story which no publishers
then was pleased about and then I just
set off one after the other
and this is what I was doing and I did
think I said now I am a writer I was
writing a lot of books that was not
realistic you know I wrote memos of the
survivors and briefing for defensive to
help for the sit-in to hell
this is my to non-realistic book before
I got roundish Acosta there's five books
which I think are some of the best
writing I've ever done and I looked at
it I thought my god this book is juicer
it's too long he's perfectly you know I
could suddenly sit so I cut out thee the
so that nobody needed an attendance of
the cross is seen just like that and now
people say what a beautiful structure it
had they only knew how all the tree that
was you know you invent whole sections
or something and then later Sandberg
refer wants to know which is true and
what isn't and you have to sit and think
you can't remember anymore
so a lot of it is invented and half of
it is true in true inverted commas it
didn't do me any good to feminists we
never liked it was very extreme
feminists of that time you know I
remember going to Sweden and some
actress coming up to me and saying this
is my book it is not your book it is not
yours
I only read the blue notebook so
kind of exaggerated hysterical rubbish
you